foreign
Burlington Virginia well welcome to the
show
uh how's it going actually it's Vermont
but uh oh I'm doing pretty well sorry
the abbreviation was wrong on my screen
you know someone's getting fired over
that I'm just kidding no it's all right
I thought I was like I didn't know there
was a Burlington Virginia but it's all
right how we doing well what can I help
with today
he's doing pretty well I'm actually uh
pretty new to your guys's shell here
I've been listening for about a month
now A buddy of mine turned me on to it
um made a lot of stupid decisions
financially over the years
uh once I started making you know really
good money I just did stupid stuff
um it's called lifestyle creep so before
yeah yeah
um so before I found you guys I was in
the process of getting uh solar put on
my house
and in doing that was taking a whole
equity loan so everything you know came
back I've been listening to you guys I'm
on baby step two hammering down as much
as I can
and I'm kind of at a point where I don't
know if I should go through with the
solar loan and get the solar put on
because
I'll be saving money on utilities
or if I should just cancel well you're
too smart for this buddy you know too
much now
yeah you're saying it's not too late to
back out of this nightmare
no I'll lose 300 bucks but it's it's not
a big deal I'll pay that stupid tax to
not pay a much bigger stupid tax by
taking out this HELOC to pay for solar
what's your utility bill
well
um I'm a HVAC guy so I put heat pumps in
this year this month was 512 dollars
give me the average if you divided it
out over 12 months it's not 500 bucks a
month
no if I average it out it's probably
300. okay
that is 3 600 bucks a year what are you
saving
30 bucks a month
you're saving 30 bucks a month
yeah it'd be 270.
okay this hurts my brain
you're saving 30 a month which is 360 a
year you're saving
well right but then when the loans paid
off I won't have to pay for electricity
what's the HELOC you were going to take
out
like total amount yeah
it was 37 I believe 37 000. what's the
interest rate variable probably
no no it was fixed at uh 3.99
so you were going to take out a 37 000
loan at four percent interest to save
360 a year
well long term I'm not going to have an
electric bill you're not going to be
alive by the time you Roi on this thing
true
look I'm doing the math for you which I
I wish the the guy trying to sell you
the HELOC did or the guy selling you the
solar uh 37 000 right this is where not
even counting interest it would take you
102 years to break even will
okay how old are you I figured but
what's your name
do you plan on living to be 136 years
old to see the light of day when you Roi
illness
no
okay I got a trade-off I got it I'm so
riled up can I I know it's ridiculous
will did you hear what George said I
mean if there's only one thing you heard
by calling another show today and I'm
glad you did I'm glad you're a new
listener is the amount of time it would
take you to Roi on that 37 000 a hundred
plus years he said I mean do you need to
know anything else but the sales guy
didn't tell you that
okay but I got an idea no I was just
thinking I wouldn't have a electric or
heating bill but that's fine but that's
ten years from now but that's not true
you would still have a bill
uh there was a national news program
that did a whole story on this because
it doesn't completely remove your
there's still a cause like it doesn't
completely wipe your energy out you need
to do the research on it actually you
don't because we already explained why
you should eat the 300 bucks and not
worry about it right I'm sure the solar
panel salesman told you otherwise yeah
but I just did some third grade napkin
math to show you that you won't live to
see the day you Roi on this but I have
an idea I have an idea to loot to to
lessen the sting of eating the 300
dollars
you're gonna eat the 300 you're not
gonna go into debt for it but uh you're
going to cash flow some solar walking
lights along the front path of your
house at Lowe's or Home Depot go get you
some of those yeah now you got some
solar energy
sorry I'm just telling this whole solar
panel thing is the next great scam
it really is yeah and people are falling
for it because they're going well yeah
utility bills are high I could save a
quick Buck if I do this by going 40
Grand into debt and roiing 100 years
from now
right and I was taking into
consideration my heating bill because
now I've got heat pumps in the house
heat pump water here so I was like
taking that into consideration as well
you know my heating bill during the
winters three four hundred dollars a
month so I was like well
maybe this will work out but then like I
said I found you guys I'm like
rethinking everything I'm so glad well
here's the deal you could save up 37 000
and pay cash for it and then you got
what you want without
the 100 Year Roi
right how do you get rid of the 60 000
in debt first so there we go of course
we're just kind of helping is that all
of your data 60 Grand
that's it I had 72
um before I started listen to you guys I
I sold a car that I wasn't really using
good hammered off two two things and now
I've got a another question is I've got
a uh a new vehicle for my wife and I
have a company Vehicles so I don't have
to pay for those but like I'm I'm even
at the point where I'm like well maybe I
should just sell this and then
get a cheaper vehicle you know what's
the loan on that vehicle we're talking
now we're making progress what's the
loan amount on that new vehicle
uh we owe 45 000 on it and it's 820 is
that on top of your 60
no that's included in the 60s what's the
car worth
uh about 45. I'm getting rid of that
thing
sell it what's your household I don't
have the cash I don't have the cash to
go and buy another vehicle and we need
one for her so what do you have in
savings
a thousand okay and what's your
household income
uh two hundred thousand good grief you
make 200 000.
save up six grand like I said take your
next paycheck get Mama an Uber for a
month or two good grief at 800 a month
payment you're still coming out I mean
you realize how ridiculous an 800 car
payment is for a depreciating asset
oh yeah I had three car payments at one
point in time and I I what are you
trying to do
no I just you know stupid and I start
making money
you're not stupid people who make 200
Grand aren't stupid you're a smart guy
that's right you're just falling for the
traps of these scummy sales people
you're falling for the traps of a toxic
money culture and the good news is you
you know too much now you're a dangerous
man with some money in your pocket and
you're about to pay off all this debt be
completely debt free and uh we are
rooting for you my man